la consécration pour le petit jeune
homme très futés reporter de son état de
nos jours on dirait grand reporter
spécialiste négocié des affaires
maintint bien sûr reconnaissable à sa
houppette et assez knickers la
consécration par la même occasion pour
son père entre guillemets rg tous deux
entre par la grande porte à beaubourg le
temple de la culture française ils vont
y rester jusqu'au 7 décembre
alors même si aujourd'hui la panoplie du
parfait journaliste a considérablement
évolué toutes les rédactions du monde
on leur tape bien fred endress teinte
analogue est un thème au fil le reporter
à la houppette vous réclame alors bougez
vous scaphandrier d'autres vaisselle 4
sur l'exposition qui consacre rg ce
bachi bouzouk d'écrivain et vous serez
nombreux à vous y rendre pour découvrir
ce héros de la mémoire collective
sacré nom d'un dieu des mers tintin
c'est 110 millions d'albums traduit en
33 langues
tonnerre de brest il est célèbre ce
petit gars moi je trouve lésé siffert
très éducatif
c'est un problème change aux enfants
sabre de bois comme rien ne ressent plus
saintes à nice qu'un autre teinte à nice
ça fera du monde pas pour le plaisir des
enfants pourtant je comprends pas
pourquoi les grandes personnel tintin
parce que ils sont trop bêtes et c'est
que pour les enfants est d'accord
d'accord les enfants mais les grandes
personnes elles aussi elles peuvent
avoir du plaisir à vivre les aventures
de tintin
à chaque âge on y trouve ce qu'on veut
et les enfants voit certaines choses
les adultes votre show
parents enfants on le sait maintenant
atteint fait l'unanimité au fait
physiquement comment vous le trouvez
vous tintin 5 ménard croit sa coupe de
cheveux son pantalon
justement qu'est ce qu'elle a de
particulier sa coupe de cheveux elle
robic je crois knickers houppette
anglais français créole serbo croate
mais de quelle nationalité il est au
concours belge
absolument mais bon on a compris la
preuve il a même été au congo belge pas
toujours sympa d'ailleurs avec les
indigènes dessinée noir avec des grosses
fermes et s'amuse quoi il a ni âge ni
problèmes financiers ni envie de
couscous plus surprenant pas même de
petite amie
c'est idiot c'est bidon et ont jamais
amoureux tintin ya jamais delphine
normal tintin sassoli de 7 à 77 ans à
cet âge là difficile de rêver encore de
corps bronzé et plus de 77 ans parce que
aborde en crise elle empêcherait pas de
lire c'est plutôt j'ai des mauvaises
gérer de la cataracte
alors je lis plus beaucoup et je
n'achète plainte à ergy c'est un temps
bien sûr mais aussi milou le professeur
tournesol et du ton et le plus
sympathique capitaine haddock le
capitaine haddock il est où le temps est
bourré comme crosby
mais les ressemblances ne s'arrêtent pas
là qu'il ne sait pas un jour identifié à
la star des reporters non parce que
l'intérieur sont quand même un jeu
claude bourret quittera jamais c'est un
jeu bourré il est quand même plus aux
questions de coût de toute façon une
chose est sûre malgré son grand âge et
pour le plaisir de tous tintin est
toujours aussi jeune
j'emploie de bourg et c'est vrai un
grand reporter